there is a muster in Central City yes
the monster triangulate to think okay
let's just triangulate Barry we're gonna
do Empire Empire of the Sun Barry what
empire strikes a fire strike back Barry
nobody seems the wiser as to why I'm
here
something about
come on you can't just go through a
stuff is trust not something that you
have on this earth hey guys it's Charlie
this is gonna be my flash episode 5
trailer video you know teasing big
Cloverfield parallax monster stuff
happening I also have news about arrow
Supergirl like other comic book TV show
stuff at the end of this - nice Empire
Strikes Back shout out I don't know if
that's a Spider Man Captain America
Civil War shout out or which is a
straight Star Wars shout out
I think it's leaning more towards Star
Wars but what a coincidence that they
also just use that reference in a big
250 million dollar Marvel movie so there
are a couple things going on in this
trailer that made me wonder if this
monster is actually real or if it's like
a fear projection because there's like a
flash villain called the thinker they
can actually like project people's fears
onto them so everyone might just be
thinking that they're seeing this
Cloverfield style monster because the
whole episode is mostly about Caitlin
like when you look at the synopsis it
just says Caitlin goes to see her mother
to find out about killer frost stuff
because her mother is this really famous
researcher but she's super cold she has
a frosty personality so that's going to
be all kinds of fun so when you think
about the title monster Caitlin is
afraid of turning into a monster the
episode might be more about fear than it
is about a literal like physical monster
because the other part of the episode
description just says a mysterious new
metahuman terrorizes the city and it's
one thing to have the powers of mirror
master like his powers look pretty
fantastic but it's another thing
completely for a normal person to be
able to morph to like create this much
mass turn into a monster this big so you
kind of think to yourself there's no way
that this could be a person it has to be
some trick there's got to be some twist
and the funny thing is is that the
episode is written by his axe tense who
wrote the runaway dinosaur last year so
he wrote a flash episode that was titled
after a story about little dinosaur boy
having courage in now he's writing
another episode about courage only
there's almost like a real-life dinosaur
running around so it's like this nice
unbroken
Lu but the other thing that tipped me
off because you look at this and you're
like it looks kind of like a xenomorph
from the alien series the closest thing
that this looks like in the DC Universe
is actually parallax like this crazy -
theme monster that's basically the
embodiment of fear the episode sounds
like it's all about fear like I said you
know Caitlyn's fears of turning into a
monster because of her powers so what
might be happening is is that you know
aside from the Caitlin arc which is
going to be really interesting is that
you know this trailer which mostly
focuses on the actual monster is all
about a person getting the powers to
make your fears manifest in like a
really broad-based way because just from
the looks of the trailer everybody on
the street we know what Barry's like
calling this into team flash sees this
at the same time so in order for that to
happen you have to have some sort of
proximity effect so you can let me know
in the comments like what do you think
is going on with this alien creature
because this definitely looks like a
monster but if it's a new metahuman
there's there's no way like a single
small person could morph into something
this big so it has to be some big twist
and I think it has something to do with
fear but I couldn't find any information
on IMDB so whatever they did they were
pretty good at keeping the secret so
we'll find out next week but let me know
what you think it is is causing people
to see this monster the other thing in
the trailer is earth 19 Harrison wells
creeping like he's speaking into the pen
like he's on some secret mission that
the other people don't know about so
that might have something to do with the
lead-up to the mid-season finale maybe
he's working with the dominators maybe
he's working with dr. alchemy it just
feel like them being so trusting
shooting that beam out into the
multiverse to all those different
planets in just expecting that whoever
comes back oh he's a Harrison wells he
solved the problem so he must be a
pretty cool dude he's just gonna totally
bite them in the ass I saw a bunch of
people wondering how long that he was
going to stick around but I think earth
- Harrison wells and Jessie quick
we'll be back somewhere around the
midseason finale I don't know if Jessie
quick is actually going to be in the
mid-season finale but like the big
killer frost episode is episode 7 so
there's still like a whole bunch of time
for them to figure out what's going on
with
crazy earth 19 Harrison wells so next
big question let me know in the comments
what do you think that he is up to what
is his secret mission that he's on the
team flash supposedly doesn't know about
whatever it is it looks like Cisco pulls
his little pen out that he was speaking
into so maybe they forced it out of him
by the end of the episode but yeah hey
there's a new round of the DC giveaway
going on right now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video and what I might
do tonight instead of doing a
traditional arrow episode video you know
short of like Black Canary coming back
from the dead is that'll do like an
arrow bonus video about Black Canary
theories was just to be clear like I
still watch like a lot of TV shows but
it just seems in general that like most
of the world is having trouble watching
the show just because of the way they
window content so it's just like hard to
do TV in the fall until like the
sprinting what everybody comes back so
what'll probably happen is is for some
of the smaller TV shows I'll be doing
like bonus videos trailer videos and
then obviously like big four night
crossover stuff and then we'll circle
back around during the mid-season finale
and see where everything's at because I
feel like there are a couple big things
that like I just absolutely have to do
but every once in a while there's an
episode we're just like almost nothing
comic book happens so I feel like
there's not a lot of need to completely
like analyze and break it down so for
people that are like freaking out that I
might not do arrow or Supergirl videos
anymore
that's not what's happening don't freak
out 0 chill it's just that there are a
couple other fun types of videos that I
feel like I can do for those that'll be
a little bit more fun especially for
people that have trouble keeping up with
the show week to week because it seems
like almost like 90% of the channel here
has trouble watching stuff week to week
so just like slowly trying to figure out
a better way of doing comic book stuff
that I would normally be doing that
everybody is able to watch so figure it
out don't worry usually like the fall is
just like a bad time in general there's
like a garbage election happening in the
United States right now it'll be done in
the middle of November so hopefully then
things will start to get a little bit
better so most of this week should work
like normal and there is like a
Supergirl Miss Martian vs. Young Justice
Miss Martian video that I want to do
that my post on Thursday or Friday
like a couple things I'm working on so
I'll just post updates on Twitter and
Facebook on when all that stuff's coming
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click up top for my mirror master
episode Easter eggs from last night and
you can click down here to learn all
about the Punisher season one and the
big defenders crossover thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight